unweit der klassikstadt weiner das
ehemalige kz buchenwald 56.000 menschen
starben hier leiter der gedenkstätte ist
der historiker jens christian wagner ja
das ist sehr befremdlich hier zu stehen
ohne besucherinnen und besucher zu sehen
das ehemalige häftlings lager ist
komplett leer eine schneewüste sozusagen
über eine halbe million menschen
besuchen die gedenkstätte normalerweise
im jahr lehre seit corona ist vieles
anders
gerade jetzt im winter erleben wir dass
in der nähe oder sogar auf den
massengräbern in buchenwald gerodelt
wird wo man sich als normal schicken der
mensch sozusagen denkt wie weg wie kann
sowas sein aber da müssen wir als
gedenkstätten das ist unsere aufgabe
dazu beitragen dass diese sensibilität
für geschichte dann auch wieder
hergestellt wird
aber nicht nur mangelnde sensibilität
sondern auch geschichts verleugnung und
offener antisemitismus wachsen
selbst bei besuchern der gedenkstätte im
gespräch kommt man dann aber sehr
schnell darauf dass es rassistisch ist
geschichtsrevisionistische
antisemitisches gedankengut ist das da
geteilt wird und das ist sicherlich im
verlauf der korona pandemie nicht besser
geworden mit den vielen verschwörungs
legenden die da geteilt wurden von denen
die meisten einen einen sehr virulenten
antisemitischen kern haben und auch
damit werden wir konfrontiert
umso wichtiger sind orte des erinnern
wer etwas an unserer offenen an unserer
humanen gesellschaft ändern möchte und
das wollen die rechtsextremisten das
wollen die rechtspopulisten das will die
afd
der muss sich der muss die axt anlegen
an unsere erinnerungskultur weil
sozusagen unsere offene gesellschaft
auch eine antwort ist auf die verbrechen
im nationalsozialismus in der nähe von
lübeck ein anderer ort und die
geschichte von philipp schlaffer ich
habe gesehen meine extremismus hat nur
zu zu tod geführt zu laut zu gewalt ich
hab da ich habe mein leben ruiniert hat
das leben vieler anderer ruiniert ich
habe meine familie wir getan
ich hab' ich habe nur leid verbreitet
mehr habe ich nicht gemacht philipp
schlager war viele jahre ein führender
neonazi also ich selber habe mir ganz
viele rechtsextreme tat ausgemacht ich
hatte hier in der mitte ein hakenkreuz
ich hatte mir hier die wappen der
waffen-ss tätowiert ich habe dann ihr
den ss totenkopf dem ich jetzt heute
eine brille gemacht habe und den mund
gegeben habe ich hatte hier ganz
klassisch den nordischen greifvogel der
den jüdischen christlichen fisch greif
und verschlingt und tötet heute arbeitet
der 42-jährige als sozialarbeiter sendet
aus dem keller seines hauses auf youtube
seine geschichte soll neonazis dazu
bewegen auszusteigen
auch ein buch hat er darüber geschrieben
braucht kein applaus von von sag ich mal
von leuten die nicht radikalisierte
dafür nicht anfällig sind natürlich ist
das schön wenn dann mehr zuschauer sind
ja weil das war das pusht den kanal
einfach in der reichweite
aber ich möchte eigentlich dass
extremisten dazu können philipp schlager
wird beschimpft auch bedroht
schonungslos erzählt er von seiner
vergangenheit und wie er nun darüber
denkt heute macht er eine sendung über
antisemitismus
ich habe den text und die melodie von
diesem lied heute noch im kopf dass ein
jude kommen lassen uns anzünden seine
synagoge wurde es gibt nur ein wort was
man sagen muss juden raus jetzt ist
schluss wenn ich nur in den text denke
habe ich die melodie im kopf und weiß
wie ich in diesem auto saß irgendwie als
junger neonazi mit anderen kameraden
kameraden unter saßen im auto und haben
zu diesem lied gegrillt und es hieß ist
dies wirklich ab in den ofen das ist ja
das erschrecken denn wie soll sich das
in ein gehirn brennt erschreckend sei
auch was ihm bei schulbesuchen als
alltags antisemitismus begegnet von
schülern die keineswegs alle nazis seien
in der klasse sind es 45 schüler so das
sind ja schon 25 prozent oder 20 prozent
seiner klasse ideen dann sagen ja ist
schon so auf dem schulhof 'niemand sich
fünf euro irgendwie leid und gibt es
nicht an diesem tag zurück dass sein
gesagt wird macht man hier nicht eine
auf jude dann rede ich überhaupt erst
mit schülern darüber was das überhaupt
bedeutet ob sie das kennt woher haben
sie das wollen sie es aufgeschnappt
wissen sie überhaupt worum es geht woher
er kommt an diesem tisch muss und so
weiter dann gibt es viele aha-effekte
überhaupt weil sie sich vorher nie
beschäftigt hat weil das so aufgenommen
wird irgendjemand bringt das in die
klasse rein dann wird das gesagt und
wird das unreflektiert weiter weiter
benutzen das ist ja auch die große
gefahr und so prägt sich ja nachher auch
antisemitismus ins gehirn das ehemalige
kz flossenbürg in der oberpfalz seit
2009 10 verfolgt man hier neue ansätze
jugendliche größtenteils mit flucht
hintergrund beschäftigen sich in einem
projekt mehrere monate mit rassismus und
antisemitismus
viele menschen die in arabisch
muslimischen kontexten sozialisiert
wurden einen regelrechten hass auf
israel und auch auf juden fliegen
das ist dann ganz eng verwoben mit dem
verschwörungs nativ das
juden ja sowieso generell reich und
einflussreich wie in deutschland
begegnen die jugendlichen auf zum ersten
mal der geschichte des holocaust viele
sind in der heimat mit judenhass
aufgewachsen
wenn ich zur moschee gehen und bett denn
da auch die leute die sagen dioden sind
alle schlecht das habe ich gehört man
muss einen jordan tor tanja ich habe
gehört wie diesen ist gut die haben
gesagt okay
alles beginnt mit palästina der kampf
gegen antisemitismus muss breiter
aufgestellt werden sagt psychologe amat
mansur der am projekt beteiligt ist die
tatsache dass mit obama migrantische
oder muslimische antisemitismus sprechen
bedeutet nicht dass wir den
antisemitismus irgend unter deutscher
irgendwie klein reden wollen
da findet unterschiedliche phänomene die
existieren sie haben ihre qualitäten
sie haben ihre ähnlichkeiten aber sie
haben auch unterschiede am ende des
projekts sollen die jungen menschen zu
botschaftern werden und in ihrem alltag
fortan gegen antisemitismus einschreiten
die denken die juden alle schlecht sind
oder da kann ich erklären also eure
gedanken ist falsch wenn man ein in
gleicher richtung sieht es gibt immer
probleme
du musst auch nach links nach rechts
ferien gemacht
[Musik]
eigentlich sollten den schülern schon
längst wieder neue teilnehmer folgen
doch corona macht es unmöglich auch
philipp schlaffer kann aktuell keine
schulen besuchen und das in einer zeit
in der verschwörungstheorien und
antisemitismus wieder wachsen
mehr als 75 jahre nach der befreiung der
konzentrationslager
[Musik]